[Music]
what's playing out on headlines and
television screens today in Venezuela is
a confrontation with a narco
dictatorship began in 1998 when Hugh
Chavez was elected he immediately began
to dismantle the democratic institutions
of Venezuela it's all in a power into
the hands of the executive that
revolution also made common cause with
no traffickers with terrorist
organizations with hostile regimes
before he died in 2013
Chavez designated Nicolas Maduro as his
successor and Maduro has used brute
force to hold on to power in 2015 the
Democratic opposition won in a landslide
in the congressional elections
unfortunately the regime has done
everything you possibly can to
consolidate its own power and to prevent
the Democratic National Assembly for an
operating we're in the midst of a
political crisis now as you have a clash
of these institutions between a strong
executive which is really a dictatorship
and the National Assembly is
representing a democratic opposition
what are your thoughts about the crisis
in Venezuela please let us know in your
comments and also let us know what other
topics you want a EEI scholars to cover
in 60 seconds